The joe rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by nine all day.
All right,
here we go.
Oh God.
Of Love.
If there is one,
he got me pin.
So a tab your arm and I slept on the floor at Chata.
Tag Out.
No team makes me sad.
I know.
Now I'm the jealous
then I don't need to prove it to you.
Yeah,
I can be angry.
Ooh.
My hands and knees,
Rosemary.
Me,
me,
the e
God of love.
Make me a fan.
Friends.
Seventies.
My innocence in the hands.
Whole,
the skin.
The taste.
Even my hips just throw.
Oh yeah.
And then I'll give them my time.
Waste.
Praise your name.
Yeah.
P
No,
they do it on my hand.
Nice.
Ooh,
wow.
Yeah.
Okay.
Me
D.
Oh,
turn and lovers.
Me.
Oh,
leaving school.
Good.
I am
as well.
Waiting for [inaudible].
Feel confused.
Feels like a trainwreck.
I all the flowers,
dad.
It ain't [inaudible] now I'm a quiet.
Okay.
I am a sound so,
so it won't you to hill mistaken and paying my toll.
Ooh,
it on my hands and knees.
It is
me.
Yeah.
Oh,
she tell me.
She tell me.
Yeah.
Awesome.
That wasn't a bummer at all.
That was awesome.
How about the ballot of Buck Angel?
Somebody?
Someone that was really helpful.